solve for x and we have x minus 8 is
equal to x over 3 plus 1 6. now the
first thing i want to do here and
there's multiple ways to do this problem
but what i want to do just to simplify
the fractions i'm going to multiply
everything times the least common
multiple of all of these guys
denominators this is essentially x over
one this is eight over one x over three
one over six the least common multiple
of one three and six is six
so if i multiply everything times six
what that's going to do is going to
clear out these fractions so these
weren't fractions to begin with so we're
just multiplying them by six so it
becomes six x minus
six times negative eight is or six times
eight is 48 and there's a we're
subtracting it right over there and then
we have x over three times six let me
just write it out here so that's going
to be six times x over three
plus six times one over six or we get
six x minus 48 is equal to
6 times something divided by 3 that's
the same thing as 6 divided by 3 times
that something that's just going to be
equal to 2x
plus 6 times 1 6 or 6 divided by 6 is
just going to be 1. so that first step
cleared out all of the fractions and now
this is just a straightforward problem
with all
integer coefficients or integers on
either side of the equation what we want
to do is we want to isolate all of the
x's on one side or the other and we
might as well isolate them all on the
left hand side
so let's subtract 2x from both sides we
want to get rid of this 2x here that's
why i'm subtracting the 2x
so let's subtract 2x from both sides
and on the right hand side i have 2x
plus 1 minus 2x those cancel out that
was the whole point so i'm left with
just this one over here on the left hand
side i have 6x minus 2x well that's just
going to be 4x if i have 6 of something
minus 2 of that something i have 4 of
that something
minus
and now i can let's see i want to get
rid of this 48 on the left hand side
because i want only x's here so let me
add 48 to both sides of the equation do
this in a new color so let me add 48 to
both sides of this equation
and on the left hand side 4x minus 48
plus 48 those cancel out i'm left with
just a 4x and on the right hand side 1
plus 48 is going to be 49 and now i've
isolated the x but it's still multiplied
by a 4. so to make that a 1 coefficient
let's multiply both sides by 1 4. or you
could also say let's divide both sides
by 4.
anything you do to one side you have to
do to the other and so you have what do
we have over here 4x over 4 is just x
x is equal to 49 over 4. and that's
about as far as we can simplify it
because these don't have any common
factors 49 and 4. let's check to see
whether 49 4 is indeed the answer so
let's put it into the original equation
remember the original equation is what
we have in green here before we
multiplied it before we multiplied it by
6. but in theory we should be able to
put it into any of these steps and the x
should satisfy but let's do it in our
original equation
so we have x minus 8. so we have 49
over 4 minus 8 should be equal to 49
over 4
49 over 4 over 3
over 3 plus 1 over 6.
so let's see what we can do here so what
we can let's see we can multiply well
like we did before we can multiply both
sides of this equation by 6. that'll
help simplify a lot of the fractions
here so if we multiply both sides of
this equation by 6 so we're going to
multiply everything
everything
by 6 what do we get on the left hand
side
6 over 4 is the same thing as 3 over 2
right so this is going to be 3 times 49
over 2. 3 times 49 over 2 minus 48
minus 48 will be equal to
6 divided by 3 is 2 so it's going to be
2 times 49 over 4 which is the same
thing as 49
over 2 and then 6 times 1 6 is plus 1.
and let's see we can well i'm just going
to i'm just going to actually just
evaluate them out i could just
essentially have to you know subtract 49
over 2 from both sides and that will
simplify things but let me just let me
just figure out what these evaluate to
so 3 times 49
49 times 3 you could think about it it's
going to be 3 less than 50 times 3 so
it's 147 but let's just multiply it out
9 times 3 is 27
4 times 3 is 12 plus 2 is
14. so 147 so this is 1 47 over 2
and then let's put this over a
denominator of 2. so 48
is equal to 96
over 2 right 96 divided by 2 is 48 i
just multiplied this by 2. so this is
minus 96 over 2 needs to be equal to 49
over 2 plus
and let's instead of having this one
let's write that as 2 over 2.
and what's 47
minus 96 so 47 minus 100 would be or 147
minus 100 would be 47 but we're going to
subtract 4 more than that so we're going
to have it's going to be or so we're
going to subtract 4 less than 100 so
it's going to be 147 minus 40 96 is
going to be 51.
51 over 2 is equal to 49 plus 2 is 51
over 2 so it all checks out